welcome to Tech news briefing for Monday
May 1st I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal
it sounds like a dream partnership Apple
reaches out and says it likes your
product and wants to work together but
some who've experienced this say they've
learned it's not always the dream
scenario they think it will be and have
accused Apple of using its Financial
might and the U.S patent system to
Vanquish smaller Rivals Apple says it
doesn't steal technology and that it
respects the intellectual property of
other companies
Aaron Tilly is the Wall Street journal's
Apple reporter and he joins me now to
talk about this Aaron you've been
hearing from people who say they feel a
bit baited and switched when they've
made these partnership deals with apple
can you tell us exactly what's going on
here yeah so there appears to be a
reoccurring pattern where Apple
they see a space and they want to get to
know it so that part of that means going
out to the market and talking to other
players and learning about what they do
so in a bunch of cases they've
approached a company
and started a sort of partnership talk
like we want to work with you there's so
many opportunities we want to dig deep
into your technology and what ends up
happening is that some of these
conversations that keep going maybe they
could lead to an acquisition on the road
but I found a few examples where it
leads to Apple just ending up hiring its
employees or learning about technology
and then just end up launching itself
launching that piece of technology and
their products in particular I found a
few cases around the Apple watch where
that pattern happened but this isn't
certainly limited just to the Apple
watch can you give us an example from
some of the people that you spoke to the
main example we point to is this company
called Massimo Massimo is this fairly
sizable company who creates pulse
oximeters these are sensors that measure
the blood oxygen level in somebody's
body so you know obviously super
important during covid when you wanted
to know the health of somebody and if
their oxygen levels were being depleted
from coveted symptoms Massimo is pretty
much the leader in that space they've
been around for a couple decades and
apple they approached them around 2013.
this is when Apple was developing the
Apple watch Apple approached them with
this kind of talk around we're
interested in what you're doing we want
to dig deep in your technology potential
Partnerships are abound we talk about
integrating your sensors into our
products I mean it was never they make
it seem like there's a big opportunity
here and what ended up happening for
Massimo is that Massimo finds itself the
target of what appears to be apple
recruiting effort a number of employees
including the chief medical officer were
recruited to Apple and Massimo the CEO
Joe Kiani he is understandably quite
concerned is this really a partnership
that is happening here so this continues
to happen in years down the road
starting 2019 he sees Apple publish a
series of patents and this describes
very similar technology the kind of
technology that Massimo and a year later
they launched the Apple Watch series 6
with pulse oximeter sensors and this it
all kind of lines up for the CEO Joe
Kiani it's this was Apple according to
him this is his perspective that Apple
comes in under the pretense of some
partnership and really they're just
looking to learn as much as possible and
take its best employees and do it all
themselves what has Apple said about
that well Apple says it isn't targeting
Massimo's employees it doesn't steal
technology it is not copied Massimo and
it respects intellectual property there
are several legal cases proceeding
around on this issue so they're both
duking it out in court currently and
apple denies all this so
like that really hinges on on this idea
of what kind of patents are approved in
the U.S can you give us a simplified
version of how the U.S patent system
works and how apple is accused of using
it to its own benefit sure so for the
past few decades according to Advocates
and activists among inventors and patent
holders is that the system has really in
recent decades been tilted in favor of
the large companies in particular there
was a law passed in 2011 called the
American Events act and under this new
law there was something that was created
called the patent trial and appeal board
this is a system that enables companies
who have been charged with patent
infringement to try to invalidate
patents that maybe haven't issued
incorrectly that they are not valid if
you take a second look and it really
opened up the floodgates for Apple to
try to take on any allegations of patent
infringement so they have become the
single biggest user of the patent trial
and appeal board and according to people
who have faced off against apple and
Executives and lawyers and people in
this community is that Apple uses this
extraordinarily aggressively so they'll
go after a company through the patent
trial and field board with many claims
filing many claims against the company
including for patents that are totally
unrelated to the dispute all intended to
sort of overwhelm these smaller entities
Apple of course denies that they use
this system to overwhelm smaller players
you know according to these folks who
have dealt with apple it's intended to
overwhelm them with legal filings
because defending against one of these
claims can cost at least half a million
and with many claims coming at them it
can quickly overwhelm a smaller player
alright that's our Apple reporter Aaron
Tilley thanks for joining us and that's
it for today's Tech news briefing for
more Tech stories head over to our
website
wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal thanks for listening
foreign
[Music]